since its 1955 opening the disneyland
resort has swelled to include multiple
theme parks which currently boasts 54
fantastic rides
from star wars to spider-man dumbo to mr
toad here's how disney super fans rank
them all now your host
walt disney
jump in jellyfish is one of the few
remaining original rides at disney
california adventure as well as the
bottom ranked experience on this list
that may be because it's aimed at kids
this pee-wee friendly parachute style
ride gently glides up its 40-foot tower
then drops you serenely part of the way
with a few more ups and downs before
slowly lowering to the ground
main street vehicles come in four
old-timey varieties the horse-drawn
trolley the chitney the fire engine and
the double-decker omnibus all four rides
are one way and slowly take you up or
down main street the drivers are
generally congenial and the ride is very
much like winding down the main drag of
a sleepy town not a huge thrill but it's
immersive enough in americana that
everyone should try it at least once the
golden zephyr is a circular rocket ride
that swings your ship over paradise bay
and that's about it
unlike the astro orbiter at disneyland
you can't control your rocket you can
however let your imagination run wild
the golden zephyr is pretty at night too
the tower is covered in lights as are
the cables connecting the rockets to the
tower it's one of the original rides
left at california adventure from its
opening days
inside out emotional whirlwind is a
reskinned flicks flyers from the old a
bug's land but built up on a platform so
you fly higher than before riley's
emotions from inside out are depicted on
the baskets which are connected to
riley's memory balls resembling a
balloon ride the tower tilts from the
top as the ride spins around giving an
up and down sensation much like life
itself
the frequently misspelled astro orbiter
is another circular rocket ride except
you can control your own rocket to go up
or down at your whim
sitting majestically at the front of
tomorrowland off main street the astro
orbiter and its golden tower announce
the future in all its gleaming glory the
ride itself can be an easy spin if you
don't move your rocket or a nauseating
ordeal if you continuously push and pull
your controller to hit the highs and
lows of the ride it's your choice
gadget a character from the chip
chippendale rescue rangers cartoon has
made a small fry friendly steel track
coaster that packs in a surprising
number of turns and drops for such a
small footprint a cartoon hand cranks
the gears taking the acorn train up the
first hill other fun touches include a
cartoon frog spitting water over the
tracks it may be a kid's ride but it's
fun for people of all ages
mater's friends square dance on a figure
eight track as you're pulled behind each
tractor in a little trailer that swings
side to side
tolerance for the ride is on two planes
how much you enjoy pulling sideways g's
and how much you like larry the cable
guys crooning as mater sings and puns
away it does get holiday overlays for
halloween and christmas as mater plows
through more jokes and themed songs
giving the ride a unique feel
the mad tea party from alice in
wonderland is a spinning ride where
visitors ride an oversized tea cup on a
rotating platform and control how fast
their individual cup spins or doesn't
sometimes you'll see a family in their
cup taking it easy while other cups are
a whirling blur of flying arms
feverishly turning the control wheel if
you get motion sickness steer clear but
if you don't this is a treat beloved or
low that nature of the ride means some
individuals may rape this much higher
than others
straight from dumbo the casey junior
circus train is a miniature railroad
with an engineer an internal combustion
engine and circus themed riding cars
it's a fun ride but high wait times when
the park is crowded probably affected
the ranking for this one only two trains
run at a time and riders are allowed to
choose which car they want to ride in
making the load time longer than it
could be
pinocchio's daring journey is a dark
ride that debuted in 1983 as part of
fantasyland's overhaul the ride follows
the trajectory of the disney film
pinocchio as the little wooden boy is
taken by the evil stromboli and forced
to perform as a living puppet
pinocchio's conscience jiminy cricket
tries to help but pinocchio is a bit of
a blockhead the best part of the ride is
nearly getting swallowed by monstro the
whale
cool but it doesn't measure up to the
other classic dark rides
dumbo the flying elephant is an original
spinning ride that is one of just 13
rides left from disneyland's 1955
opening as with the astro orbiter riders
can control whether their elephant
cockpit goes up or down though this ride
is gentler than the tomorrowland
attraction the line for this ride can be
up to an hour on a busy day as it's
quite popular for families to ride
together that family friendliness may be
why it ranks higher than the orbiter
however what it lacks in thrills it
makes up foreign bonding time
although autopia has been through
multiple changes since it debuted on
july 17 1955
some things remain the same such as the
noxious gas fumes emanating from the
backs of the cars as they travel the
winding disney freeway the cars travel a
whopping six miles per hour along a
guided track though riders may control
the pedal and steering wheel to a degree
this one's more for kids as adults get
enough road rage on the la freeways just
getting to america's favorite theme park
we just drove
2460 miles just for a little roy wally
entertainment the moose says your
clothes i say you're open
previously known as the sun wheel and
then mickey's fun wheel pixar pal around
is 150 feet tall and boasts two kinds of
gondolas fixed and swinging thrill
seekers will want the swinging cars
which slide back and forth toward the
interior of the wheel before warned
though like most ferris wheels the ride
is slow not just in revolutions but
because there are 24 cars to load the
red car trolley has four stops along
buena vista street and hollywood land
and like its main street vehicle
counterparts is a bit of nostalgia for
guests while also being used for a song
and dance show throughout the day if you
don't feel like walking from near the
park's entrance to hollywoodland hop the
red car trolley and roll down the street
in vintage style
the mark twain riverboat ride has
survived since 1955 and remains a
beloved attraction guests can sail down
the rivers of america and frontierland
on this giant paddle wheel steamboat
pretending they're on the mighty
mississippi guests can explore the four
decks or just chill out on the rail
taking in the sights the boat is named
after the pen name of one of walt
disney's favorite writers samuel
langhorne clemons or mark twain as he
was professionally known it's a serene
trip and pretty tame and also 14 minutes
long which may have dropped it in the
rankings
grab a paddle as you and 19 other guests
all row your way down the rivers of
america in a real canoe you'll get in
some arm work to balance all the walking
at disneyland plus you may ride
alongside the occasional deer or moose
though they might be made of plaster
however the amount of paddling does tire
some people out even though the guides
do most of the heavy work
unlike the cars of autopia the
disneyland monorail is powered by
electricity as it cruises around the
park you can board either in
tomorrowland or downtown disney though
the ride only travels 2.5 miles it takes
20 minutes round trip which is a big
time commitment if you're trying to cram
in a lot of rides the ride also shuts
down in extreme heat because it's not
air
it also closes for the fireworks shows
so availability is limited
the ride that started it all sort of
king arthur carousel one of the original
1955 opening day rides was inspired by
the griffith park merry-go-round in los
angeles that walt disney used to love
visiting with his children it was also
the scene of a key moment in the 2013
film saving mr banks it may not be the
most cutting-edge ride but for the
nostalgic it's an old-fashioned classic
that's the most disney ride in all of
disneyland
first known as snow white and her
adventures on disneyland's 1955 opening
day and then redone as snow white's
scary adventures in 1983 the ride now
called snow white's enchanted wish has
received yet another makeover unveiled
on april 30th 2021 the dark ride
features new effects including the smell
of baked pies the improvements may
change the ride's future ranking as
given the new moniker it's probably fair
to say it's now less scary
the silly symphony swings features
individual and tandem swings that whirl
you through the air over paradise bay
the telescoping tower undulates as it
spins giving a more exciting ride it's
not uncommon to see riders with their
arms extended as though they are flying
while the william tell overture plays
though it's the type of ride you could
find at a carnival or county fair this
one has extra disney magic
the storybook land canal boats covers
most of the same territory as the casey
junior circus train except much closer
to the models depicting various disney
stories
starting at monstro's mouth a tour guide
narrates your placid trip it's a
leisurely relaxing way to take a load
off while reliving some of disney's
greatest hits in a kid-friendly
format jesse's critter carousel is a
smaller merry-go-round than the king
arthur carousel it features various
varmints from the woody's roundup
cartoon in toy story 2. guests can hop
on a bunny if they like for instance the
ride is more geared towards kids and
revolves slower than its disneyland
counterpart but it's pretty cute all
told which may explain why it ranks
higher than the original
the jungle cruise one of the 13 original
rides just got a facelift reopening in
july 2021 in conjunction with the
release of the jungle cruise feature
film the ride is known for its tour
guides and their corny jokes which will
remain but several of the older scenes
which were problematic were removed or
revamped one thing that hopefully
remains getting to see the backside of
water
ladies and gentlemen
the backside of water
[Applause]
leave it to goofy to take a wild mouse
style coaster and make it sillier
goofy's sky school is a bit wilder than
gadget's go coaster though much tamer
than the incredi coaster still it does
have scary moments because each sudden
turn makes it appear the plane is about
to go flying off the tracks adults and
more adventurous kids will probably
prefer the larger coasters but this one
still delivers what it promises
the sailing ship columbia is a replica
of the real columbia vessel which was
the first american ship to
circumnavigate the globe it's a
leisurely 15-minute trip around the
rivers of america where you'll see many
of the same sights as from the mark
twain riverboat and the davy crockett
explorer canoes albeit from a different
perspective you can also pretend you're
repelling pirates as the columbia is
used as a pirate ship during fantasmic
the disneyland railroad has four stops
around the park tomorrowland new orleans
square mickey's toontown and main street
station the trains are steam powered and
can take guests around the parks in 18
minutes though most people hop on and
off to get from one land to another the
tomorrowland stop is a fan favorite
because between it and main street
guests are treated to scenes from the
grand canyon and the primeval world
yep you get to see dinosaurs fighting at
disneyland
the little mermaid ariel's undersea
adventure is a dark ride with clamshell
cars that go underwater to follow ariel
as she gives up her voice to pursue
prince eric while her friend sebastian
the crab pops up here and there to keep
an eye on her it's super colorful and
filled with song but it's also kind of
short and skimps on ursula's defeat
possibly to avoid scaring children
filled with animatronics and so many
doors this ride is based on 2001's
monster zing it replaced one of disney's
least successful rides ever superstar
limo in which you were a paparazzo
trying to take pictures of celebrities
instead of that baffling premise the new
one where you follow mike and sully on
their adventure getting baby boo back to
her own bedroom is a much better fit
alice in wonderland is a dark ride with
a bit of outdoor travel through alice's
adventures in the mythical wonderland
the caterpillar cars twist and turn on
the winding leaf track and down the
rabbit hole as a combination of
animatronics and animation provide
entertainment it also has several scenes
from the disney movie of lewis carroll's
classic tale telling a cohesive story
from beginning to end it's both kid and
adult friendly and colorful too
based on 1988's who framed roger rabbit
roger rabbit's cartoon spin combines the
fun of a dark ride with two connected
cars that can be spun independently
benny the cab drives you through roger's
adventures while judge doom's pinch
weasels try to erase you with the dip
part of the ride's repeatability is
going back to see the things you missed
if you spun your cap too fast it's a
boisterous wacky ride that almost always
has a long line but with plenty of
toontown-based items to view while you
wait
mr toad's wild ride has been driving
guests to hell since disneyland's
opening day in 1955 though its facade
was thoroughly revamped in 1983 and the
ride touched up each buggy is on a
guided track that barrels through london
as mr toad's terrible driving skills
have you narrowly avoiding certain death
until you don't
the dark ride combines moving painted
scenes blacklighting and loud noises fun
for adults scary for kids
this boat ride features animatronic
children and animals from all over the
world singing it's a small world after
all it's a song loop that will
inevitably become an earworm you'll be
humming the rest of your day and
possibly the rest of your life the ride
also gets an annual christmas overlay
and while some disney fans hate the ride
lines can still reach 90 minutes or
longer on crowded days
the matterhorn bobsleds ride was the
first coaster at the park the ride has
two different tracks that wind and dip
through the interior and exterior of the
mountain with a yeti that tries to catch
your sled
the ride has been refurbished many times
over the years from new cars to an
upgraded yeti and just reopened in june
2021 following repairs
in this dimly lit ride which is based on
the 1977 film of the same name
everything is infused with a palpable
whimsy sure to delight
a wobbling beehive car takes a guided
track through three tales
as pooh tries to get his beloved honey
and his friends plant him a heartwarming
birthday celebration helping its ranking
is the fact that everyone can ride
including babies
luigi's rolican roadsters gets high
marks from guests of all ages
apart from being totally adorable the
ride has thrills galore even though it
doesn't appear to be moving fast from
the outside trackless gps technology
allows the cars to dance with each other
each dance depends on the song playing
giving it high repeatability for riders
formerly an underwater attraction with
mermaids and a goofy looking sea monster
the submarine voyage was closed and
eventually updated with a pixar theme
leaps in technology led to imagineers
using underwater projection to present
characters from 2003's finding nemo
going about their daily lives as guests
view them from the submarine's portholes
the ride can be a bit claustrophobic the
seats are small and there are often long
wait times but this ride's cuteness
makes up for the problems
a ride and a game buzz lightyear astro
blasters lets guests control the
direction their spaceship faces as they
use oversized laser guns to shoot
targets and save earth from buzz
lightyear's nemesis zerg
certain targets are worth more points
than others and hidden targets are worth
the most giving this ride a unique
competitive aspect that many park goers
embrace
peter pan's flight is the highest rated
ride in fantasyland as well as the
highest rated of the original 1955 rides
on this list
with its classic design that allows you
to fly over london peter pan's flight is
the kind of ride that disney fans flock
to as early as possible in the day in
order to ensure a short wait time
because once that time hits about 40
minutes it doesn't ever seem to go down
star tours is a flight simulator ride
that has added several destinations from
the star wars franchise over the years
as well as simulator upgrades 3d and
special effects inside the cabin the
unpredictable appearances of various
star wars characters as well as the
different destinations possible to visit
each trip makes star tours one of those
rides guests get off and get right back
in line for
big thunder mountain railroad isn't just
a runaway mine train it's a haunted one
the engineerless train races through
pitch dark tunnels over hills and around
bank corners at a top speed of 36 miles
per hour the ride feels faster at night
and will have you sliding side to side
if you don't hang on
one tip the further back you sit in the
train the more intense your ride will be
good luck
the incredicoaster takes you on a wild
ride as the incredibles chase baby jack
jack who doesn't have control of his 17
powers yet incredicoaster is 121 feet
tall with one inversion and a max speed
of 55 miles per hour speakers in the
back of each seat play music and
narration you can even smell the num num
cookies mr incredible waves at jack jack
some coaster enthusiasts complain about
the lack of air time and g-force but
unless you're hardcore you'll probably
enjoy the ride
if you've ever wanted to see if you can
beat the kessel run in less than 12
parsecs you can pilot the millennium
falcon at disneyland for practice the
cockpit seats six two each of pilots
engineers and gunners
each smuggling run is different
depending on the skill set of all
involved the ride is like a video game
as you earn or lose credits based on
what you steal and how much you damaged
the ship everything about it is really
well done
hop into a doom buggy for a truly dark
ride as you visit the other side and its
population of ghosts and ghouls
parts of the ride can be scary for
children but most of it is simply fun
the ride gets an overlay from september
through the christmas holidays each year
as jack skellington from a nightmare
before christmas takes over but the
ride's popularity is a double-edged
sword the line can get up to three hours
long
grizzly river run is a white water raft
ride where you may get a little wet or
soaked to the bone the hotter the day
the longer you'll have to wait to board
too each raft holds eight riders and
floats freely in the rushing river the
rafts are designed to spin especially on
the final drop which adds to its
unpredictability it's probably safe to
say no two rides are ever alike
splash mountain combines elements of a
dimly lit ride with a flume as your log
floats down a snaking river dips three
times and then drops five stories into a
briar patch for now that is the ride's
ranking may change after it's rethemed
to 2009's the princess and the frog but
exactly when that refurbishment will
happen or how long it will take is still
unknown but if you want to ride it the
way it is now you'll want to do it soon
toy story midway mania is another
combination ride game but in 3d and with
a toy cannon you operate by pulling a
rope how fast you shoot depends on how
fast your arm gets tired each game
presented is different and the ride only
spins between games like many of the
rides in the top 10 you want to hit this
ride as soon as you get into the park or
you will have a long wait
sorin around the world replaced 2001's
original attraction soarin over
california though the ride's popularity
hasn't seemed to wane guests are taken
hang gliding around the world courtesy
of a unique imax experience that
combines film wind and subtle smells for
a 4d experience it's almost impossible
to ride soarin around the world and not
hear clapping at the end which might be
the most effective ranking metric of all
this indoor coaster has a surprise drop
and deeply banged curves to simulate
hurtling through space in a rocket
because it's mostly in darkness space
mountain's top speed of 35 miles per
hour feels much faster especially when
sitting in front there are speakers in
each seat playing music timed with the
ride and a great special effect in the
beginning that makes it feel as if the
ride is slowly spinning before launch
the ride has had two overlays
halloween's ghost galaxy and the star
wars themed hyperspace mountain and a
long wait time that matches its classic
status
this free fall gantry lift ride was the
first marvel themed attraction in a
disney park when it was originally the
twilight zone tower of terror it had one
pattern of drops but in keeping with the
guardian's more chaotic nature the ride
now has six different drop patterns
depending on which of its six songs
plays over the mayhem that
unpredictability coupled with the
enhanced graphics and story has boosted
the ride's popularity the darkly lit
boat ride lasts 16 minutes you'll
witness various pirate shenanigans with
an occasional sighting of jack sparrow
from the pirates of the caribbean film
franchise though the ride has undergone
updates and additions throughout the
years to keep it fresh and modern the
pirates still plunder and the ride still
has a couple of good drops to boost your
adrenaline just like walt wanted he's
trying to escape he's got one foot on
the dock and one foot on a rocky boat
you know as the people go by they see
him he's struggling and everything
indiana jones adventure features a long
hidden line that winds through the
temple of the forbidden eye for lots of
fun before you ever even get to the
transports
once on board it's a herky-jerky jaunt
past poisoned dart-blowing skeleton
warriors and a gigantic snake as you try
to survive those and several other
perils the ride is so popular that in
april 2021 disneyland temporarily
introduced a virtual cue for it to
control the crowds waiting outside
slot car toys come to life in this
combination dark ride coaster that is
themed to 2006's cars drive through
beautiful ornament valley and past
several of the cars characters after
which your vehicle is prepped in luigi's
casa de la tires or ramon's body shop
before a side-by-side race over rolling
hills
webb slingers is the first new ride to
open at avengers campus and from all
accounts it's a fun if short hybrid game
ride it's hard to say how good the ride
is as recency bias may be affecting its
ranking many reviews are positive but
some on the various disney-related
facebook groups have noted wrist pain
from the motion needed to shoot webs
while others have grumbled that in order
to get the highest scores you need to
purchase 60 dollars in accessories so
that's not cool
star wars rise of the resistance is
hidden away in batu's forests to avoid
detection by the nefarious first order
it is really like five rides in one
including flight simulation trackless
gps and well we don't want to give it
all away
suffice to say it is one of the best
attractions ever devised when the
virtual cues go live in the parks you
can feel the anticipation as people try
for boarding groups if you're hoping to
ride it all we can say is may the force
be with you
i don't know about you folks but it's
way past my bedtime the morning comes
around early
and that's one of my favorite times here
too
so good night
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you